Hey guys. Just kind of like a massive major workout. My thighs are pumped. My thighs are pumped. Everything's pumped up so big. I can't even, like, I pass a mirror and I'm like, wait a minute, where did Sean go? And he's right here.
大家好。这就像是一场巨大的力量训练。我的大腿练得紧绷极了。我的大腿紧绷极了。全身都充血涨得厉害。我甚至都不能，比如说，我路过一面镜子，然后在想，等一下，肖恩去哪了？他就站在这里。
So, but who am I kidding? I didn't work out. I never work out. Welcome to SmartLess. Smart. I woke up this morning about the NASA thing. Did you read this thing today? No, what happened?
所以，不过我在开什么玩笑？我根本没锻炼。我从来不锻炼。欢迎收听 SmartLess。聪明。我今天早上醒来的时候看到了关于美国宇航局的那条新闻。你今天读到这个消息了吗？没有，发生什么事了？
That the Voyager, you know, it's like 15 billion miles away. Yeah. And they don't quite know what's, there's something going on with it where they're not receiving correct information, but they're still receiving information. And I'm interested in that shit. Did I just lose everybody? No.
就是“旅行者”号，你知道的，它离地球大约有150亿英里远。对。他们不太清楚是怎么回事，它好像出了点故障，传回的信息不太对，但它确实还在传输信息。我对这种破事挺感兴趣的。我是不是把所有人都聊无聊了？没有。
Yeah, you don't want to try to stay away from just half stories. Okay. Yeah, that's what I was going to say. I was going to say, like, I'd be interested if you gave me actually anything interesting to think about. Okay. Well, I can tell you what happened with my, I got my MRI back from my neck.
对，你可别想只挑半截故事说。好吧。对，我本来就想这么说。我想说的是，如果你能提供哪怕一点真正值得思考的东西，我可能会感兴趣。好吧。那我可以告诉你我的情况，我拿到了颈椎的核磁共振报告。
This I want to know about you. Okay. And what they say, it's a... No, I got a better story. It's a pain in the... Ah, but... Okay, so listen, so this is a true story. As you can notice, I got my hair cut yesterday, right?
这个我想听。好吧。他们说，这真是个……不，我有个更好的故事。这简直让人头疼……啊，不过……好吧，听着，这是一个真实的故事。如你所见，我昨天理发了，对吧？
It's really, really short. And I got a little color in there, too. So Scevo, blah, blah, blah, joke, joke, joke. Skevo, Greek, fantastic. Oh, hang on. Is that what we do now to fucking, the fuck is going on? What do we have a kid's birthday party? So I'm sitting there.
剪得非常非常短。我还稍微染了个色。所以斯凯沃，巴拉巴拉巴拉，开个玩笑。斯凯沃，希腊风格，太棒了。哦，等一下。难道这就是我们现在要做的，他妈的，这到底是怎么回事？我们是在办儿童生日派对吗？所以我正坐在那儿。
Wait, wait, wait, wait, you just glossed over the rinse. You put a rinse in there, huh? What was the name of the color on? on that reds it's usually something like chestnut forever or something like that no that's my profile on my on your weight is no it's two words chest nuts not no it's not on chest right please not on chest dot com da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da we really got to get a snare drum in here oh i got that i got that swistle oh boy here it comes
等等，等等，等等，你刚才轻描淡写地带过了那个漂染。你在里面弄了个漂染，是吧？那个红色的颜色叫什么名字来着？通常是什么“永恒栗子”之类的。不，那是我在你的体重上的个人资料。不，是两个词，栗子，不，不是在chest上。请不要在chest点com上……我们要在这里加一个小军鼓。哦，我听到了，我听到那个口哨声了，哦，天哪，它来了。
Here we go, Shecky. Go, Sheck. There is. So, listen, so wait, so I'm sitting there. And you know Chris McMillan, who does your hair, Jason. Sure. So he's sitting on the other side and his station across. And I go, Chris, get me something like a piece of candy or something.
来吧，谢基。上吧，谢克。这不就来了。所以，听着，等一下，所以我正坐在那儿。你知道克里斯·麦克米兰，就是给你理发的那个人，杰森。当然。所以他坐在另一边，在对面他的工位上。我说，克里斯，给我拿点什么东西，比如糖果之类的。
I want, I wanted some sugar or something sweet. And he goes back in the bag, he's like, I don't have anything. You want me to make your peanut butter sandwich? I was like, no, I don't want that. So I'm sitting there and Scovus cut my hair. And like 10 minutes later, he hands me a bag of chocolates. He sent somebody out. to get me chocolate.
我想吃点糖或者甜的东西。他回到包里去找，说，我没有什么吃的。你想让我给你做个花生酱三明治吗？我说，不，我才不要那个。所以我坐在那儿，斯凯沃在给我剪头发。大约10分钟后，他递给我一袋巧克力。他派人出去给我买巧克力。
It's full service over there. Isn't that the nicest thing in the world? Chris did or Skevo did? Chris did. That's pretty nice. He's not the guy who owns the salon. It's pretty nice. I know, Chris.
那边可是全方位的服务啊。这不是世界上最贴心的事情吗？是克里斯还是斯凯沃做的？是克里斯做的。那真是太好了。他可不是沙龙的老板。这真的很棒。我认识克里斯。
I know for Tracy. I can't believe you're asking them for snacks in there. Why's just go in there and behave yourself? Also, there wasn't a pleas in there. You were like, hey, Scevo, give me some candy. You said, hey, Chris, give me some candy. I know.
我知道特蕾西。真不敢相信你在那里管他们要零食。为什么就不能好好坐在那里安分点呢？而且你刚才也没说“请”。你当时就像是：“嘿，斯凯沃，给我点糖。”你说的是：“嘿，克里斯，给我点糖。”我知道。
What is going on? You're a tyrant. He's so sweet. I can't believe that, that he actually sent somebody out to get me chocolate. Also, who eats peanut butter in a hair salon? The hair's going to get stuck in it. Gross.
这到底是怎么回事？你这个暴君。他太好了。真不敢相信他竟然真的派人出去给我买巧克力。还有，谁会在美发沙龙里吃花生酱？头发都会粘在上面。太恶心了。
That sounds disgusting to me. Well, anyway. Listen, I don't want to keep our guest waiting. I do. Okay, listen. So with all this momentum, this hilarious momentum, let's go ahead and intro the guest. I'm super excited about our...
这听起来太让人反胃了。好吧，不管怎样。听着，我不想让我们的嘉宾等太久。我想。好吧，听着。既然有这股势头，这搞笑的势头，我们就直接介绍嘉宾吧。我超级期待我们的……
Don't make me do it again. Okay, I'm super excited about it. It's just at arm's length. So what's so weird, that little slide was, like, I'd have to drive 10 miles to buy one of those, and yours is just arm's length. That's right. I don't know what the search terms are for it.
别逼我再重复一遍。好吧，我超级期待。它就在触手可及的地方。真奇怪，那个小滑梯，我得开车10英里才能买到一个，而你的就近在咫尺。没错。我都不知道搜它的关键词是什么。
I'm super excited about our sweet, kind, funny, cutest pie guest today. I had the pleasure of thinning next to her as we both voiced characters in that animated show I did last year, Q-Force, and she made me laugh really hard. She's the epitome of a workaholic. She doesn't stop working. And I'm not sure why she's on smart list because she graduated valedictorian of her class
我超级期待我们今天这位甜美、善良、有趣、超级可爱的嘉宾。我有幸坐在她旁边，因为我们去年一起为我参与的那部动画片《Q-Force》配音，她把我逗得前仰后合。她是工作狂的化身。她永远不会停止工作。我不知道她为什么会来SmartLess，因为她可是以班级第一名的身份从米ルトン中学毕业，然后进入哥伦比亚大学主修文学。
from Milton Academy before attending Columbia as a lit major. She starred in films like Obvious Child and Gifted. She's guest starred in Parks and Rex and Girls and Everything Funny You Can Think of. Earlier this year, she started with our friend Charlie Day in the Amazon original rom-com, I want you back. And she is, of course, the star of my favorite animated character of all time, Marcel, the Shoe's on.
她主演过《劣质童年》和《天才少女》等电影。她客串过《公园与游憩》、《都市女孩》以及你能想到的所有搞笑作品。今年早些时候，她和我们的朋友查理·戴一起主演了亚马逊原创爱情喜剧《我想要回你》。当然，她还是我所有时代最喜欢的动画角色——贝壳里的马塞尔的配音。
It's a wonderfully talented and hysterical, Jenny Slate. Jenny Slate. It was really great. Jenny. Hi. Hi, Jenny. Thank you for being here. This is so cool.
她就是才华横溢、让人捧腹大笑的珍妮·斯蕾特。珍妮·斯蕾特。真是太棒了。珍妮。嗨。嗨，珍妮。谢谢你能来。这太酷了。
Oh, my gosh. It's so, I don't know if your guests say this a lot, but like the energy mounting waiting to be revealed and then I'll, like, it depends on all your personality is. But if you're like, oh my gosh, what if I'm like a bad surprise and no one cares or, and then you guys are so funny and I was laughing and I didn't trust the mute. I was like maybe like maybe I'll laugh so hard. I'll bust through the mute. As the youngest of five children, I'm a bad. surprise. So...
哦，天哪。这真是，我不知道你的嘉宾们是不是经常这么说，但那种等待被揭晓的积蓄的能量，然后我会觉得，这取决于你们每个人的性格。但如果你在想，哦天哪，万一我是一个糟糕的惊喜，根本没人关心，或者，然后你们又这么搞笑，我刚才一直在笑，而且我不太信任静音键。我在想，也许，也许我会笑得太大声，直接把静音键给震破了。作为五个孩子中最小的一个，我就是一个糟糕的惊喜。所以……
Oh, there it is. Sean, don't you hear you. You know what, Jimmy? I'm so sorry. First of all, hi, nice to meet you. Hi. You've never met. You get the Lego Batman movie together.
哦，这不就来了。肖恩，听不见你说话。你知道吗，珍妮？真的很抱歉。首先，嗨，很高兴认识你。嗨。你们俩从来没见过。你们一起演过《乐高蝙蝠侠大电影》。
Oh, wait. We've met brief. But we didn't record. I think we briefly in passing, but this is our first conversation. We've never had an actual dialogue. So, yeah. Double snub.
哦，等等。我们见过一面，很简短。但我们没有一起录音。我想我们只是擦肩而过，但这才是我们的第一次对话。我们从来没有真正交谈过。所以，是的。被无视两次。
What about no chatting at the craft service table? Did you guys not They didn't have one Sean tell Tracy what a craft service table is Craft Service is where they feed the cast off the side like with a line I'm just food on tables It's a snack table
那茶歇区不能聊天是怎么回事？你们没有……他们没有茶歇区吗，肖恩？告诉特蕾西什么是茶歇区。茶歇区就是他们在旁边给演员提供食物的地方，排着队拿食物。我只是说桌子上有吃的。那就是个零食桌。
It's a snack table for everyone Easily said Yeah Wait I read somewhere Jenny that you are like Because I'm looking at where you are right now I'm not in my home I'm not in my home That's what I was going to say
那就是给大家准备的零食桌。很容易理解。对。等等，我不知在哪看到过，珍妮，你好像是因为我正在看你现在所在的地方我不在家里我不在家里我刚才就想这么说
Okay so that's what I was going to say Listener it looks like she's in a supply closet Do you run in a travel agency What's going on? I'm in a supply closet Okay Look I'm in a supply closet That looks like you got last night's dress
好吧，我刚才就想这么说。听众朋友们，她看起来像是在一个杂物间里。你是在经营旅行社吗？这到底是怎么回事？我是在一个杂物间里。好吧。看，我在一个杂物间里。看起来你身后挂钩上还挂着昨晚的裙子呢。
hanging on a hook behind you too. There's a toilet underneath me. There's a toilet. I hope so that's where you want it to be. Are you on a boat? Are you in the head on a boat? Are you just suffering from colitis right now and you just want to stay ready?
我下面还有一个马桶。有个马桶。希望那正是你希望它在的地方。你在船上吗？你在船上的厕所里吗？你现在是不是正遭受结肠炎的折磨，所以随时准备着？
You know, I don't feel safe. I don't feel like myself unless there's a toilet truly screwed in with full-on plumbing into just whatever space I'm in and I need that. Even for podcasts. Directly under you. Yeah. So I live for most of the year in a small town in Massachusetts by the ocean and I live on a little peninsula and we have Wi-Fi that is like internet that my mother-in-law put in there in like, you know, the late 90s, I want to say. And no one has ever decided to improve upon it. And so when it's raining, literally it's like raining today, it's not, there's not even really a breath of wind. But the internet becomes very bad. And so my husband owns the general store. So I came up here with my computer and my like power cord trailing like a little tail and was like, can I use it?
你知道吗，我没有安全感。如果一个空间里没有一个通过完整管道牢牢安装好的马桶，无论我在什么地方，我都觉得不像我自己，我需要这个。连做播客时也一样。就在你正下方。Yeah. 所以我一年中的大部分时间都住在马萨诸塞州海边的一个小镇里，我住在一个小半岛上，我们家的Wi-Fi就像是我婆婆在，你知道的，我想大概是90年代末装的那种。而且从来没有人决定去升级它。所以每当天下雨的时候，就像今天这样在下雨，甚至连风都没有。但网络就会变得非常糟糕。所以我的丈夫经营着一家杂货店。于是我带着我的电脑来到这里，电源线像一小截尾巴一样拖在后面，问：我能用一下吗？
Jenny, this is crazy. Can you, I know there's not a breath of wind. Can you, what's the five-day outlook? I'm going to tell you what, well, we're going to get into the high, the high 70s is what I heard. Now, Jenny, this sounds like an ideal life you live. Tell us slow about this peninsula and what did you say most of the year. The general store. Does he wear an apron?
珍妮，这太疯狂了。你能，我知道没有一丝风。你能说说五天天气预报吗？我告诉你吧，嗯，我听说气温会升到70多华氏度。那么，珍妮，这听起来你过着一种理想的生活。给我们慢慢讲讲这个半岛，你刚才说一年中的大部分时间都在这。杂货店。他戴围裙吗？
Here's the thing. In ideal life, still have the same personality that I had in L.A. So I'm waiting for the adjustment to kick in for that chillness. That chillness to get right. Maybe you need to move to Chillmark. Come on. Hang on a second. Sean?
事情是这样的。过着理想的生活，但我依然保持着我在洛杉矶时的性格。所以我还在等待那种松弛感在自己身上生效。那种松弛感才能真正到位。也许你应该搬到奇尔马克去。得了吧。等一下。肖恩？
So whereabouts keeping your safety in mind so you don't need to get too specific. Whereabouts are you in Massachusetts? Sure. I can see Martha's Vineyard from where I live. I'm in... Are you in Woods Hole? I'm not in Woods Hole. I'm in what they call South Coast, Massachusetts.
为了你的安全着想，不用说得太具体，你在马萨诸塞州的什么地方？当然。从我住的地方可以看到玛莎葡萄园岛。我在……你在伍兹霍尔吗？我不在伍兹霍尔。我在他们所谓的马萨诸塞州南海岸。
And I'm from Massachusetts, and I did not know that this area existed. And my husband and I were kind of... Oh, yeah. Where are you from, Jenny? I'm from Milton, Mass. No shit, huh? Matter of fact, I used to know a kid... No, he's from fucking.
我是马萨诸塞州人，但我甚至不知道还有这个地方。我和我丈夫当时……哦，是的。你来自哪里，珍妮？我来自马萨诸塞州的米尔顿。不是吧，真的吗？事实上，我以前认识一个小孩……不，他他妈是……
He's from Bill Ricka, but... I knew this other kid from Milton. Fucking good kid. You should see this dude. What's his name? His name is Sully, obviously. Oh, yeah, everyone is. Yeah.
他是从比利里卡来的，不过……我认识另一个来自米尔顿的小孩。他妈的是个好孩子。你真该看看这家伙。他叫什么名字？他叫萨利，显然是的。哦，对，大家都叫萨利。对。
But he lives, he lives, he lives, he lives, he lives, he lives, he lives, in Milton, and he works in Pibati. That's where my cousins live. Are you shit me in fucking Peebittany? I'm not kidding. Do they work for the Edison? What's that? Like the Edison, like the. Yeah, the fucking power company.
但他住在，住在，住在，住在，住在，住在，住在米尔顿，他在皮博迪工作。我的表亲就住在那里。你他妈是在逗我吧，在皮博迪？我没开玩笑。他们是在爱迪生公司上班吗？什么？就像爱迪生电力公司那种。对，就是那个他妈的电力公司。
Yeah, it is. Yeah, you know. Jenny Slate, how did you, so did you just stumble into this general store one day and you say, hey, handsome fell in an apron. No, ding, ding, ding, and the bells went when she opened the door. I don't see a ring on that finger. What about we get a malt? Yeah, yeah.
对，就是它。对，你懂的。珍妮·斯蕾特，你是怎么，你是偶然有一天走进这家杂货店，然后说：“嘿，长得挺帅的小伙子，还戴着围裙”？不，当她推开门的时候，“叮铃铃”，铃铛响了。我可没看见那根手指上有戒指。我们要不要去喝杯麦芽奶昔？对，对。
Listen, it's not how it went. I wish that that would be really nice. that's so romantic. But in fact, I met my husband in... Online? Well, in the Arctic. In the Arctic. Oh, really?
听着，事情可不是这样的。我希望是那样，那可真好。那太浪漫了。但实际上，我和我丈夫是在……网上认识的？嗯，在北极。在北极。哦，真的吗？
In the Arctic. What do you mean? What do you mean? It's like it all just sounds like, you know, those people who try to have stuff to make them more interesting, but they're actually like basic, so they say stuff like this. This is a great pitch. Keep going. So you guys meet in the Arctic.
在北极。什么意思？什么意思？这听起来就像是，你知道的，那些试图表现得很有趣，但实际上很平庸的人，才会说这种话。这个切入点太棒了。继续说。所以你们俩在北极相遇了。
Uh-huh. What happens? So she's in the Arctic. Yes, she's in the Arctic. She's an artist She's in the Arctic She's there for art But what she does find is love
嗯哼。然后呢？所以她在北极。是的，她在北极。她是一名艺术家。她在北极。她是为了艺术而去。但她找到的是……爱。
By the end you realize that love is art And art is love And she's standing on the end of a peninsula With a toilet underneath her Yeah Can I just say that we love this We'd like to take this off the table We'd like to take this off the table now
到最后你才会发现，爱就是艺术，艺术就是爱。而她正站在半岛的尽头，屁股底下还踩着个马桶。Yeah. 我能说我们很喜欢这个吗？我们想把这个从桌面上撤下来。我们现在就把这个从桌面上撤下来。
Truly First time I've ever sold anything in the room Wait wait so you met in the Arctic What were you doing in Arctic Norway I was making a movie there and my friend wrote the movie and her now husband is best friends with my now husband
说真的，这是我在房间里卖出的第一单。等一下，等一下，所以你们是在北极认识的？你在北极挪威做什么？我在那里拍一部电影，我的朋友写了这部电影，而她现在的丈夫是我现在丈夫的最好的朋友。
and so they and I was there and they invited him to come there and like hang out to Norway Was it a setup or just a visit? Well they it was just a visit I guess there wasn't a lot of pressure put on it so you didn't know it was a possible setup did he know it was a possible setup?
所以他们，我在那儿，他们邀请他去那儿玩，去挪威。这是一场刻意的安排还是一次普通的拜访？嗯，他们，这只是一次普通的拜访，我想当时并没有施加太多的压力，所以你并不知道这是一次可能的相亲？他知道这是一次可能的相亲吗？
He must have to like pack your bags and fly all the way For what? There's this great girl here. He must have had some sort of carrot there, right? Did he know? Well, he lived in Amsterdam, so we didn't go that far. You know, it's not like he came from Massachusetts. That would be, like, totally.
他肯定知道，否则怎么会收拾行李大老远飞去？为了什么？这儿有个好女孩。他心里肯定有所图，对吧？他知道吗？嗯，他当时住在阿姆斯特丹，所以其实没那么远。你知道的，他可不是从马萨诸塞州大老远跑来的。那才叫彻底呢。
Is he from Amsterdam? No, he's from Massachusetts, but he was living in. No, he's originally from Mass, too. What town is he from, too? Oh, let's revisit this joke. We live in his childhood home. Oh, right. Sorry, I forgot.
他是阿姆斯特丹人吗？不，他是马萨诸塞州人，但他当时住在……不，他本来也是马萨诸塞州人。他也是哪个镇的？哦，让我们重新审视一下这个笑话。我们住在他的童年故居里。哦，对。抱歉，我忘了。
No, no, it's Will's fault. It's Will's fault. No, I should let her run his course. Yeah. You know what? You know what Bateman, fuck, yo. Shut the fuck up, Beaman. Oh, my God.
不，不，这是威尔的错。这是威尔的错。不，我应该让她把话说完的。好吧。你知道吗？你知道吗，贝特曼，他妈的，去你的。闭上你他妈的嘴，比曼。哦，天哪。
Jenny, you, the reason why I asked about where you're sitting right now because it does look like a utility closet. I'm in the closet, yeah, yeah. Okay. Pause. Anybody? Hang on, oh, let me just do it in advance. Does anyone groundball?
珍妮，我之所以问你现在坐在哪里，是因为它看起来确实像个杂物间。我在壁橱里，对，对。好吧。暂停。有人吗？等一下，哦，让我提前说一下。有人懂这个梗吗？
Just to bank it. Just to bank it. I came out of there years ago. Okay, there you. Okay. So, but you've ever seen Vaudeville? Because Sean would love to walk you through some of the...
就当存个档。就当存个档。我好几年前就从那里面出来了。好吧，给你。好吧。所以，不过你看过杂耍滑稽戏吗？因为肖恩很乐意带你了解一些……
Every time on the set of Will and Grace, they all did that to each other. I read somewhere once that you were like a massive OCD clean freak, because I am a little bit of that too. I am. Yeah. Yeah, I've got a problem.
每次在《威尔与格蕾丝》的片场，他们都会这样互相开玩笑。我以前在哪里看到过说你是个严重强迫症的洁癖狂，因为我也有点那样。我是。是的。是的，我有点毛病。
I'm not. You do? What's it like for, what's happening for you? Like, did you have a messy childhood, Jenny or something? Sorry, Jay. Yeah, I did. I did have a messy childhood. Wait, Jenny, don't drop your voice and get real real with us.
我可没有。你也有？你平时是怎么样的？你有个混乱的童年吗，珍妮什么的？抱歉，杰伊。是的，我有。我确实有个混乱的童年。等等，珍妮，别压低声音，跟我们说点走心的话。
I did. Oh, boy. Yeah, I did have a messy child. I think I was more like me adjusting in my jeans. I did. I did have a messy childhood. Hi. I did.
我有。哦，天哪。是的，我确实有个混乱的童年。我想我当时更像是在调整自己的牛仔裤。我有。我确实有个混乱的童年。嗨。我有。
I did. I had a messy childhood and but very clean grandmothers like tidy houses and there was just like a big obvious like, oh, I'm way less stressed out at both of my nana's houses than in our house where it's like crazy. It's like crazy. I'm the same way. I grew up like an amazing. So then your OCD comes from trying to create order and cleanliness as opposed to trying to avoid germs.
我有。我有一个混乱的童年，但是我的两个奶奶都非常爱干净，家里总是收拾得井井有条，这形成了鲜明的对比，让我觉得：“哦，呆在我两个奶奶家里，可比呆在我们那个乱七八糟的家里轻松太多了。”简直就像疯了一样。我也一样。我长大的地方就像一个惊人的……所以你的强迫症其实是来自于试图创造秩序和干净整洁，而不是为了避免细菌。
Yeah. I don't think I have. I mean, obviously I'm kind of like at the COVID level of afraid of germs that maybe most people are. But for me, a tidiness means like untidiness means like an unsettled mind. and it like makes me feel crazy and there are like little things that like I don't understand why you would ever leave anything open
对。我觉得我没有。当然，我对细菌的恐惧可能达到了新冠时期的那种程度，大概和大多数人差不多。但对我和来说，整洁意味着……不整洁意味着心神不宁。这会让我觉得抓狂，而且有些小细节我实在无法理解，为什么有人会把东西敞开放着。
like why you would leave a cabinet open the dishwasher a jar that's crazy to me with a toothpaste tube for me it's not for me it's not it's more I'm with you on the people who can leave a cupboard that much open I'm like it's crazy close it I was just my friend Eli what else are you leaving open right
比如，为什么要让橱柜敞开着，洗碗机敞开着，罐子也开着？这对我来说简直疯了，还有牙膏盖。对我来说不是，对我不是。我更赞同那些能把橱柜开那么大一条缝的人，我觉得这太疯狂了，把它关上。我刚才我的朋友埃利……你还把什么东西敞开放着？
what? Because if you leave those things open What else are you leaving open? Holy shit. Holy shit. Right, right. Hey, wait, Sean, you're not a... First of all, Jason, the term OCD is we ever used.
什么？因为如果你把那些东西都敞开放着，你还把什么敞开放着？卧槽。卧槽。对，对。嘿，等等，肖恩，你可不是……首先，杰森，强迫症（OCD）这个词可不是随便用的。
It's not OCD. Just to be clear, it's not OCD. So nice try. It's the same way that everybody says that, I don't know, we just use a lot of these terms that are just, you know, a little overhead. Sorry, man, I'll work on it. Yeah, okay, thanks.
这不是强迫症。把话说清楚，这不是强迫症。所以，少来这套。这就跟所有人都会说……我不知道，我们就是喜欢用这些有点被过度使用的词。抱歉，老兄，我会注意的。好吧，谢谢。
I'm a little intense today, Jenny, because my... We interrupted him right in the... the middle of it. What were you blasting by's and what was today? No, just doing it, just doing a little boxing, bro. Oh, right on. Right on. Were you winning or? I hope so because I was up against the bag.
我今天情绪有点急躁，珍妮，因为我的……我们正说到点子上，把他打断了。你刚才在猛烈抨击什么，今天又是什么情况？没有啦，就是练练拳，老兄。哦，原来如此。原来如此。你赢了吗？我希望如此，因为我是在对沙袋出拳。
All right, so Eli. But Eli would, he would go, when we were in Atlanta and I'd come to the kitchen in the morning and there'd be four glasses, some cups and whatever stacked next to the sink and I'd go, and stuff open I'd go, at least
好吧，那就说埃利。但埃利会，他会，当我们在亚特兰大时，我早上走进厨房，水槽旁边堆了四个杯子、一些马克杯还有各种乱七八糟的东西，然后我会说……至少
forget I get you're not going to put it in the dishwasher can you not put it at least in the sink it is how much it's easier gravity would take your hand down even further into the sink and run some water in it and run some water in it and just leave it and he literally at one point just kind of like he goes yeah I don't know yeah
算了，我知道你不会把它放进洗碗机，难道你不能至少把它放进水槽里吗？这有多难？地心引力甚至能让你的手顺势把杯子放得更深一点进水槽，然后在里面冲点水，冲点水然后留在那里就行了。而他居然有一次就直接来了一句，他说，对啊，我不知道，对啊。
because you got a deal on this roommate huh yeah yeah Scotty can't handle when there's actual like pieces of food in the sink too like if I just put a plate down he has to rinse it out Yeah, I always clean the food, make sure there's no food in the sink, but I don't really put the dishes in the dishwasher. He likes to do that.
因为你在这个室友身上捡到宝了，对吧？对，对。斯科蒂受不了水槽里有真正的食物残渣，如果我把盘子放进去，他必须把它冲洗干净。对，我总是清理食物，确保水槽里没有食物残渣，但我不太会把盘子放进洗碗机。他喜欢干这个。
He likes to do that. Oh, that's nice. And now, a word from our sponsor. And now, back to the show. Jenny, I don't know if you're like this. I like things to be orderly and stuff. And at the same time, I'm not like a, I'm not a germaphobe. But I just like things as certain to be kind of clean and sort.
他喜欢干这个。哦，那挺好的。现在，听一段广告。现在，回到节目中。珍妮，我不知道你是不是也这样。我喜欢井井有条的东西。与此同时，我又不是那种，我不是一个洁癖。但我就是喜欢某些东西保持干净和分类。
And sorted. Yeah. I like that, too. I like to display my kitchenware like it is sort of a useful art installation. When people, like, move the bowls around, I'm like, okay. But, like, I know it's not okay to be unchill about that. But then when sort of the people are gone, I'll put it back. But I mostly I'm just like, yeah, I like to, I think it's about respect.
分类存放。对。我也喜欢这样。我喜欢把我的厨房用具陈列得像一件有用的装置艺术品。当别人把碗移来移去时，我在心里会想：好吧。但是，我知道对这种事过于较真是不对的。不过等他们走后，我还是会把它放回原位。但我大部分时候只是觉得，是的，我喜欢，我觉得这是出于尊重。
I really do. And I like how it feels to, like, close the circle. like when I make dinner every night and like while the thing is I was just saying this to a friend like I guess this is a big thing I love a clean station and when whatever's on the stove
真的。而且我很喜欢那种“画上句号”的感觉。就像我每天晚上做饭的时候，当锅里的东西……我刚才还在跟一个朋友说这个，我想这是一件大事：我喜欢保持操作台干净。无论锅里在煮什么，
getting you know having its final you know moment on the stove I do all the dishes I can yeah yeah I love it I feel so good to me I get that you know what I'm gonna share with you guys a story that I haven't really told you before tuck in which was I think I was kind of messy
在炉子上做最后的收尾时，我会把所有的碗盘都洗干净。对，对，我太喜欢了。这让我感觉太棒了。我懂的。你知道吗，我要跟你们分享一个我以前从没讲过的故事。竖起耳朵听着，我想我小时候挺邋遢的。
when I was younger I went to all boys boarding school And when I was there, I was in seventh grade, I was 12. And hang on, it gets mildly, mildly interesting. Okay. And I, one day, and the guy who ran the house kept telling me, you got to clean your room, got to clean your room. Finally one day I came back, and my shit was everywhere.
当我年纪更小的时候，我上的是全男寄宿学校。在那儿的时候，我读七年级，12岁。等一下，这个故事稍微，稍微有点意思。好吧。然后有一天，管理宿舍的那个人一直对我说：“你得打扫房间，你得打扫房间。”最后有一天我回来时，我的东西到处都是。
And I came back, and all my shit was gone from my room. And I go, where's my stuff? And he goes, come with me. And he'd taken all my stuff and put it in garbage bags and put it in the back of his car. And he drove me six miles away. And I had four garbage bags full of stuff, and I was a little 12, you know, and these big bags of stuff,
我回来后，发现房间里我所有的东西都不见了。我说：“我的东西呢？”他说：“跟我来。”他把我所有的东西都收拾好装进垃圾袋，放到了他的车后备箱里。他开车带我走了六英里远。我有四大袋子的东西，我当时才12岁，你知道的，拎着这些大袋子的东西，
and he was like, put him down, and he said, hopefully now you'll learn to clean your room, and he drove away. And so I had these four huge bags, and six miles, and I thought, how am I going to do it? So I started doing, like, two bags, 50 yards, go back at the other two bags, so they were too big. Are you kidding me? No, I swear to God.
他把东西往地上一扔，说：“希望现在你能学会打扫房间了。”然后他就开车走了。所以我带着这四个巨大的袋子，在六英里的路上，心想：我到底该怎么把它们弄回去？于是我开始用这种方法：拎着两个袋子走50码，放下，再回去拿另外两个袋子，因为袋子实在太大了。你在逗我吗？不，我发誓。
And at a certain point, I thought, like, I'm going to fucking break. Like, what's going to happen here? And I was like, you know what I've got to do? and I just opened and I started putting everything on in jackets and whatever and I managed to get most stuff on and then just had a small bag left of stuff and I walked like a Michelin
到了一定程度，我心想：我他妈快要崩溃了。这到底会怎么样？然后我想：我知道我该怎么做了！我打开袋子，把所有能穿的东西都套在身上，夹克之类的通通穿上，我设法穿上了大部分东西，只剩下一小袋杂物，然后我走起路来就像米其林轮胎人一样。
true story and I walked back and I came I remember crossing the first soccer field towards my house and him seeing me way sooner than he thought he was going to see me and I was carrying the shit but I was wearing everything and I felt like a fucking king and I was like fuck you I figured it it out, you dummy.
千真万确。我一路走回去，我记得当我穿过第一个足球场朝宿舍走去时，他看到我的时间比他预想的要早得多。我扛着那些破烂，身上穿戴着所有的衣服，我觉得自己像个他妈的国王，心想：去你妈的，我搞定这事了，你个笨蛋。
And then did you just throw it all over your room again? But you know what? Last lap on me. From then on, I was much better. I was much better about cleaning my stuff. This was a boarding school? Yeah. This was 1982.
然后你是不是又把东西全乱扔在房间里了？但你知道吗？吃一堑长一智。从那以后，我好多了。我在清理自己的东西方面变得好多了。这是一所寄宿学校？对。那是1982年。
Wow. Wow. I remember when my dad got blasted drunk one night, which was very, very often, he came home. What? And the dishes weren't done, so he's really furious about that. Did he take it Uber, do you think? They took all the dirty dishes, and we had linoleum tile on the floor in the kitchen. floor and he put a dirty dish on every single tile so you couldn't walk on the kitchen floor
哇。哇。我还记得有一次我爸爸喝得酩酊大醉，这种情况非常非常普遍，他回到了家。什么？而且碗盘还没有洗，所以他对此非常愤怒。你觉得他是叫Uber回来的吗？他把所有的脏盘子都拿出来，我们厨房的地面铺的是油毡瓷砖。他把一个脏盘子放在每一块瓷砖上，这样你根本没法在厨房地板上走路。
oh so he was a psycho too he was a little bit of a psycho yeah god darn we've really got to find him for a very special christmas episode of smart list we're gonna that's he's gonna be my miss this is a recurring theme jenny just so you know by the way um and also sorry sorry jenny we'll get back to you in just two seconds oh no oh i got to get shit is that my dad jennie can you bring the fucking bounty up to the front I mean more fucking bounty. Got the phone, Jenny. God damn it. Jenny, answer it?
哦，所以他也是个神经病？他确实有点神经病。天哪，我们真的得请他来参加一期《SmartLess》的非常特别的圣诞特辑。我们将要……这将成为我的……顺便说一句，珍妮，这是一个反复出现的主题。而且，抱歉，抱歉，珍妮，我们两秒钟后就回来。哦，不，哦，我得去拿……这是我爸吗？珍妮，你能把百宝纸巾拿到前面来吗？我是说更多百宝纸巾。接着电话，珍妮。该死。珍妮，接电话啊。
We're the fucking trashmacks. Answer it. Let's see what it is. If it's an order for some milk or something. Somebody answered it. The machine got it. Somebody answered it. What if you answered the phone?
我们是该死的垃圾。接电话。看看是谁打来的。如果是一个订牛奶之类的电话。有人接了。电话录音接的。万一你接了电话呢？
The person said, you get off this fucking podcast right now. You shut your goddamn computer and you get off the fucking podcast with your Hollywood friends. So wait, Jenny, I want to ask you, you've done a million voiceovers like, and you're regular. Big Mouth and Bob's Burgers, right? Yeah, and the Great North, it's on Fox. And the Great North on Fox. I mean, it's so, why voices?
那个人说：“你现在立刻给老子滚出这个播客！关掉你该死的电脑，滚出这个有你那些好莱坞朋友在的破播客！”所以等等，珍妮，我想问你，你做过无数的配音工作，比如你是常驻嘉宾。像《大嘴巴》和《开心汉堡店》，对吧？对，还有福克斯的《大北方》。还有福克斯的《大北方》。我的意思是，这太……为什么选择配音？
Like, when did you learn, like, you could do all of these different things with your voice? I honestly feel like I didn't know that, I didn't know this could be, like, an actual job that you can do a lot. And I don't know if you guys feel this way, but, like, I think it is the most fun. It's so, it's like, it's challenging creatively, but it's really also really easy. Not that I'm showing up in my PJs, but, like, do you? You hear these, do you hear these ladies behind the door? That's good, it's good, it's good at Mo.
就像是什么时候你发现，原来你可以用自己的声音做所有这些不同的事情？老实说，我觉得我以前并不知道，我不知道这可以成为一份真正可以经常做的工作。我不知道你们是否有这种感觉，但我觉得这绝对是最有趣的工作。它非常有创意挑战性，但实际上又非常简单。倒不是说我是穿着睡衣去工作的，不过，你？你听到门后面那些女士的声音了吗？这很好，很好，这在莫（Mo）很受欢迎。
No, we haven't asked, are you in the supply, are you in the supply room of the general store? Yeah, between the groceries and the books. No, are you really in this, like, is that true? Yeah. Oh, wow. And right now, it's, so it's 131 there, so you've got the lunch rush. So is Ben slapping together a bunch of pastrami sandwiches and, you know, who's number 35? Yeah.
不对，我们还没问，你是在杂货店的杂货间里吗？对，在杂货区和书店之间。不对，你真的在……这是真的吗？对。哦，哇。现在那里是下午1点31分，正是午餐高峰期。所以本（Ben）正在手忙脚乱地做一堆过去拉米三明治，然后，谁是35号？对。
So he owns the store, but he doesn't, like, work here every day. He and his brother. So his great grandmother used to come to this store. His family has lived in this town for a really long time. And during the pandemic, he and his brother bought the store and, like, did a little work on it. And they put a bar in here in a bookstore. And so he's kind of like, he's like the store owner. And then he comes here every day to do, like, little things for the store.
所以他是店老板，但他并不是每天都在这里工作。他和他的兄弟一起。他的曾祖母以前就经常来这家店。他的家族在这个小镇上住了很长时间。在大流行期间，他和他的兄弟买下了这家店，并做了一些改造。他们在这里加了一个酒吧和一个书店。所以他有点像是店老板，每天都会来这里处理一些店里的小事情。
But there's a lovely woman named Marianne, who is the manager. And she is letting me be in her office. Can you still do all your book? voiceover work, given the Wi-Fi limitations out there? I can, but sometimes it's really bad. Like, I do it in the linen closet between my bedroom and my daughter's bedroom, and I have a little baby. Yeah, she's 17-month-old. Oh, congrats.
但这里有一位可爱的女士叫玛丽安，她是经理。她让我借用她的办公室。鉴于那里的Wi-Fi限制，你还能完成所有的配音工作吗？可以，但有时网络真的很糟糕。比如我在卧室和女儿卧室之间的亚麻储藏室里录音，我还有一个小宝宝。对，她17个月大。哦，恭喜。
That's so amazing. First of all, I thought of the name for your autobiography, if you ever want one. Here we go. Sure, let's go. Closets, because you have a lot of closets in your life. You've got to get the slide flew out, Sean. Or just my life in closets, you know? It's really clever.
太棒了。首先，我想好了如果你想写自传的话可以用的书名。来吧。好，说来听听。名字叫《壁橱》，因为你的生活中有很多壁橱。你得把那个滑梯扔了，肖恩。或者就叫《我在壁橱里的生活》，你知道的？这真的很机智。
Yeah, thank you. So who was the tougher transition from you from living single and having all your stuff in an orderly way? Was it harder for you to get used to living with Ben or the 17-month-old? What's been the bigger transition? Great question.
对，谢谢。那么，从单身生活、一切井井有条的状态转变过来，对你来说更艰难的过渡是什么？是习惯和本一起生活，还是照顾那个17个月大的宝宝？哪个才是更大的转变？好问题。
Thanks, ma'am. That's a really good question. Take your time. It does come down to the neat freak thing. I think it was harder with the baby. Because also, like, Ben, you know, understands what I say. And so when I'm like, I don't like when that's like that, He doesn't just be like, you know, like he...
谢谢你，女士。这确实是个好问题。慢慢来。这确实归结到那个强迫症的洁癖问题上。我觉得带孩子更难。因为话说回来，本能听懂我说的话。所以当我表达“我讨厌那样”的时候，他不会只是……
He can understand a threat when he hears one. Right, that's right. Yeah, whereas the baby just doesn't understand my threats yet. Isn't that amazing how you cannot negotiate with something that doesn't speak your language? Like, that was a big, big lesson for me. Like, I can't just say, well, you're not having, you know, dessert tonight or whatever. Like, they don't care. For the first couple of years, you've got to just deal with it.
他听到威胁时还是能听懂的。对，没错。是的，而宝宝现在还听不懂我的威胁。你不觉得很神奇吗，你根本无法和一个不说你语言的生物进行谈判？对我来说，这真是一个非常非常深刻的教训。比如，我不能只是说：“好吧，你今晚不能吃甜点啦”之类的。因为他们根本不在乎。在头几年里，你只能硬着头皮应付。
Yeah. So, Jason, what was the age that your kids finally were able to understand? I'm going golfing today. Like, what was the... Because for a while, they just... You know what I mean? Yeah, that was... They were 12.
所以，杰森，你的孩子们到多大年龄时才终于能听懂诸如“我今天要打高尔夫球”之类的话？大概是几岁？因为有一段时间他们根本……你懂我的意思吗？对，那是……他们12岁的时候。
But wait, so, Jenny, so you have a 17-month-old daughter. Yeah. And you guys... And now you're firmly living back in Massachusetts, and Ben and his brother have opened the general store, and you're there, and you've kind of... Are you done with the West Coast? Are you done with L.A.?
但等等，所以，珍妮，你有一个17个月大的女儿。是的。你们俩……现在你们已经坚定地搬回马萨诸塞州生活了，本和他的兄弟开了杂货店，你们也在那儿，你已经有点……你是彻底离开西海岸了吗？你不再待在洛杉矶了吗？
Are you done with New York? Are you just like, I'm going to, this is where, for now, in your mind, are you like, this is my life now living here? I like it here more, but we still have my house in L.A. On the east side. On the east side. Zoe said? Here's the thing, on the east side, on the east side, in Silverland.
你不再待在纽约了吗？你是不是觉得：这就是我目前的生活，在你的心里，你觉得这就是我在这儿的生活？我更喜欢这里，但我们在东区依然有在洛杉矶的房子。在东区。佐伊说的？事情是这样的，在东区，在东区，在银湖。
By the way, that's a Massachusetts thing to say, by the way, which is like, oh, must be nice. Must be nice. Yeah, it must be nice. What does Ben think about Los Angeles? He likes it a lot. He, I mean, we had two years there before the baby was born and he was like, whoa, I can't believe you just pick an orange off the tree and you go for hikes and it's like very chill.
顺便说一句，那是一种马萨诸塞州人的说话方式，意思是：“哦，那可真不错啊。”一定很爽吧。对，一定很爽。本对洛杉矶怎么看？他挺喜欢的。我的意思是，在孩子出生前我们在那里住了两年，他当时感叹道：“哇，真不敢相信你可以直接从树上摘个橙子吃，还能去远足，这里太悠闲了。”
I mean, we don't have like a, I don't know, like a super flashy lifestyle. So I think he was like, this is vacationy. Like, this is pretty vacation here, which it is. And my best friends live all around us and everything. but I will say about our house in L.A., like, it's a beautiful, small old house. I bought it when I was single, and I was, like, a heavy stoner, and, like, the refrigerator is not even in the kitchen. It's in, like, a tiny room off the kitchen. And at the time, I was, like, I was single, and I was, like, it's, like, under the Tuscan Sun.
我的意思是，我们没有那种，我不知道，那种特别浮华的生活方式。所以我猜他会觉得：“这感觉像在度假。”这地方就像度假一样，确实如此。我的好朋友们都住在我们周围，应有尽有。但我得说我们在洛杉矶的那栋房子，那是栋漂亮的小老房子。我单身时买的，当时我还是个重度瘾君子，冰箱甚至都不在厨房里。它在一个紧挨着厨房的小房间里。当时我还是单身，心想，这就像电影《托斯卡纳艳阳下》一样。
Like, I'm just going to buy an old house and just live in here and have all my shirts, and, like, this will be very romantic for me. And then he came, you know what I mean, like, just like, oh, my blouses, like, it's just, me and my blouses, and I just don't give a hoot anymore about anything. I'm just living in my old home. And then Ben came to live with me, and I was like, oh, my God, it's so messy in here all like, with two people even. It's crazy. And Ben's like, where are all these shirts from?
就像我只要买下一栋老房子，住在里面，拥有一堆衬衫，这对我来说会非常浪漫。然后他来了，你知道我的意思吗，就像是：哦，我的衬衫们，这只是我和我的衬衫们，我对其他任何事情都不在乎了。我就住在我的老房子里。然后本搬来和我一起住，我心想：哦，天哪，两个人的东西怎么这么多，这里太乱了。甚至只有两个人都觉得乱。太疯狂了。本看着问：“这些衬衫都是哪来的？”
He's like, what? You never told me that you had so many blouses. We need to open a general store, yeah. Right, totally. Just drove him to that. So anyway, so I was like, oh, I love this house. Then he came, and I was like, oh, there's kind of a lot of stuff in here now with two people. And, but I felt like it was fine.
他问：“什么？你从来没跟我说过你有这么多衬衫。”我们得开家杂货店了，对吧。完全正确。直接把他逼得去开店了。所以总之，我当时想：哦，我很喜欢这房子。然后他来了，我心想：哦，现在两个人住在这里，东西确实有点多。不过我觉得也还好。
And then now with the baby and also we got a dog during the pandemic, like a beautiful, large border collie mix, that house is like, it's just really hard. It's way too small. And the stairs are really loud. You're okay, well? Yeah, I'm fine. Take a minute, man. Sorry, you're open your mouth. Clean the microphone a little bit, I guess.
然后现在有了孩子，而且在大流行期间我们还养了一只狗，一只漂亮的大边境牧羊犬混血，那栋房子简直……实在太难住了。空间太小了。而且楼梯声音特别大。你还好吗，韦尔？对，我很好。花点时间，老兄。抱歉，你张开了嘴。清理一下麦克风吧，我想。
I'm sorry. Jesus Christ. I was like my favorite, favorite truly will never. have a better joke than burping. I mean, sorry about that. Sorry about that, you guys. Welcome to Barstall Sports. So, but you guys have decided we're going to,
对不起。天哪。我刚才那个，我最喜欢的、真正永远不会有比打嗝更好笑的笑话了。我是说，真是不好意思。真是不好意思，各位。欢迎来到巴斯托体育频道。所以，你们俩决定了，
what is your child's name? Her name is Ida, IDA. So you guys said, let's, we're going to raise Ida in Massachusetts. Not out here in L.A. Yeah, good, good choice. Tell me what's happened. They were like, where do you want to live? And she said, I don't know.
你们孩子的名字叫什么？她叫Ida，I-D-A。所以你们说，我们要把Ida在马萨诸塞州抚养长大。而不是在洛杉矶。对，好，明智的选择。快告诉我发生了什么。他们当时问：“你想住在哪里？”她说：“我不知道。”
Or Idaho. Oh, you got it. Thanks. What happened to your weed, your weed addiction? Did you, did you crack that while you were pregnant? You got rid of all that? Or are we back into? No, no, no, no, she doubled down when she was pregnant.
或者爱达荷州。哦，你懂的。你那点大麻瘾怎么处理的？你在怀孕期间戒掉了吗？你把那些全都戒了？还是说我们又重操旧业了？不，不，不，不，她怀孕的时候变本加厉了。
What do the fuck do you think? Yeah, I went straight to mess. I'd like to go wide with that. I'd like to go wide with that on a podcast about how I doubled up. You're fine. Nine months of the babies here. I got to just do all the drugs. Yeah.
你他妈觉得呢？对，我直接吸毒过量了。我很乐意在一个关于我是如何变本加厉的播客里大肆宣扬这一点。你没事吧。孩子出生后有九个月。我只能把所有的毒品都试一遍。对。
No, I. Is it legal in Massachusetts like it is out here in California? I think it is. I think it is now. I think it is. I actually, I had like a bad moment of, like, I don't know if it's possible, but I kind of think I overdosed myself on weed. You know, like, when it was not with a joint or anything.
不，我。这在马萨诸塞州像在加利福尼亚那样合法吗？我想是的。我想现在是的。我想是的。其实，我有过一次糟糕的经历，我不知道这是否可能，但我当时觉得我好像自己大麻吸食过量了。你知道的，就那种，不是通过抽大麻烟。
Like, I used to smoke a lot of weed and I could smoke as much as possible, I guess, it seemed like. But I took a CBD gummy that my friend was like, oh, you. need to activate it with the THC dropper. And she was like, but you, and it was like, because I had like a back issue. I don't think CBD is really real, but that might be controversial. Either way, she was like, if you want it to work, you have to use the, yeah, the THC dropper. And she was like, but you smoke so much weed that, you know, it says between one and three droppers, you should probably take three droppers. So I was like, cool, I'll take three droppers.
我以前抽很多大麻，我想我大概能抽无限多吧。但我吃了一颗CBD软糖，我的朋友说：“哦，你需要用THC滴剂来激活它。”她还说，因为我有背部问题。我不觉得CBD真的有什么用，这可能有点争议。不管怎样，她说：“如果你想让它起效，你必须使用THC滴剂。”她接着说：“但你大麻抽得那么多，说明书上说一到三滴管，你大概应该直接吃三滴管。”所以我当时想：酷，那我吃三滴管。
And then. You had to call your mom. I took the three droppers. And I just, I mean, it was like, I think it was like the worst experience of my life during which I tried to watch the movie Amelian couldn't figure out what language it was in and was just like, what is this?
然后。你不得不打电话给你妈。我吃了三滴管。然后我，我的意思是，那简直是我人生中最糟糕的经历，期间我试图看电影《天使爱美丽》，结果根本看不懂它到底是用什么语言拍的，脑子里只剩下一个念头：这到底是什么鬼？
That movie's so good. Oh man, yeah, I'm trying to work it into stand-up now but it's still like a little scary that this happened. You know, it's like it's not exactly funny yet because I actually think I did almost die. And I threw up like outside of my bathroom because I like couldn't figure out how to get over the threshold. Like just crazy shit.
那部电影太棒了。哦天哪，是的，我正试图把它写进我的单口喜剧里，但这事现在想起来还是有点吓人。你知道的，它现在还没那么好笑，因为我当时真的觉得自己差点就死了。我还吐在了浴室外面，因为我当时连怎么迈过门槛都不知道。简直疯狂透顶。
Went to bed with all my clothes on, my boots. Like some like little zipper up booties, like got in the bed that way. I need to call for help. I need to call for help. And then it's too late, Jenny. It's too late. And then I looked. It was 6.45 p.m.
穿着所有的衣服和靴子就去睡觉了。就像那种小拉链靴子，就那样钻进被子里。我得呼叫求救。我得呼叫求救。然后就太迟了，珍妮。太迟了。然后我看了看。当时是下午6点45分。
And I was like, oh, it was just, it was so bad. And it was truly like, oh, my God. I really was like watching Amelie being like, when did this movie get so fucking scary? And what language is this? What is this? Like, I don't know. I used to love this. Her hairstyle.
我就想，哦，这真是，太糟糕了。真的就像是，哦，天哪。我当时真的就像在看《天使爱美丽》，然后心想，这部电影什么时候变得这么他妈恐怖的？这是什么语言？这是什么？就像，我不知道。我以前很喜欢这个。她的发型。
was so great and everything just looked crazy. But anyway, so then the next day, my friend, you know, it was Jane Levy. Do you know her? Yes, so, no. Yeah. So she gave me the THC thing. Anyway, so she was, she called me and she was like, I got all your texts about
太棒了，一切看起来都很疯狂。但总之，第二天，我的朋友，你知道的，是简·列维。你认识她吗？对，所以，不。对。所以她给了我那个THC（四氢大麻酚）的东西。不管怎样，她给我打电话说，我收到了你所有的短信，关于
the patriarchy. Uh-oh. And I was like, uh-huh. And she was like, I, Jenny, I'm so sorry. It wasn't one, not one to three droppers.
那个父权制。哦哦。然后我就说，呃哼。她说，我，珍妮，我太抱歉了。不是一滴到三滴管。
It was, it was, I misspoke. It was one to three drops. And so I took like, like, 120 times the dough. Yeah, and I like ruined my mind. And then, and I was like, I guess I'm off weed. And like a couple months later, I thought I'll just take a little hit and try and get back in. And it was like, it went right back to where I had been that eating. So I'm just done forever.
是，是我说错了。是一滴到三滴。所以我就服用了大概，大概相当于120倍的剂量。对，然后我感觉我的大脑都毁了。然后，我就想，我想我再也不碰大麻了。几个月后，我又想，我只抽一小口，试着重新开始。结果它又回到了我当时吃药时的那种感觉。所以我彻底永远戒了。
Yeah. I'm not going to try it. Oh, my God. So she saved you. She saved you. Yeah, in a way, she saved me. Wow, that's so crazy. And we will be right back.
对。我不打算尝试了。哦，天哪。所以她救了你。她救了你。对，某种程度上，她救了我。哇，太疯狂了。我们马上回来。
And now, back to the show. Jenny, speaking of, like, getting freaked out and stuff, you know, your Netflix special called Stage Fright, you know, which is so fucking great. I loved it so much. You talk about, I love the way it was shot, by the way. It's so cool. But anyway, you talk about, like, fear and how you hate it,
欢迎回到节目。珍妮，说到那种吓得魂飞魄散之类的事，你知道，你的Netflix特辑叫《舞台恐惧》，你知道的，太他妈棒了。我太喜欢了。你谈到，顺便说一句，我很喜欢它的拍摄方式。太酷了。总之，你谈到了恐惧以及你如何讨厌它，
and you love it, and it motivates you and how people say, just be yourself. And you were like, that's the worst advice because there's a million people in my head. How do you choose? Right, Dick. So how do you talk about like the love and the hate of performing live?
又如何爱它，它如何激励你，以及人们怎么说，做你自己就好。而你说，那是史上最烂的建议，因为我脑子里有一百万个人。你该怎么选？对吧，迪克。所以你如何谈论现场表演又爱又恨的感觉？
Like what is it you? What freaks you out about it? I like it so much, but it must be like what like adrenaline junkies are like, I guess. I mean, I don't know. But not the guy that does the free solo. I actually think that, I sound like an old woman, but that really makes me angry that he does that.
比如是什么让你对它感到害怕？我非常喜欢它，但这一定就像极限运动狂热分子那样的感觉吧，我想。我是说，我不知道。但不是那个玩无绳徒手攀岩的家伙。实际上我觉得，我听起来像个老太婆，但这真的让我很生气，他竟然那样做。
There's another one. There's another one that makes him look like... There's the one that he talks. about the other guy, the Canadian kid. Wait, what? Yeah, isn't it called the alpinist? Oh, yeah, yeah, and that one's really sad. The alpinist.
还有另一个。还有一个让他看起来……还有一个他谈到另一个家伙的片子，那个加拿大男孩。等等，什么？对，那部不叫《阿尔卑斯山人》吗？哦，对，对，那部真的很悲伤。《阿尔卑斯山人》。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. A man, oh, man, what a document. Yeah. Most of them don't end with, like, don't have amazing endings. You know what I mean? No. They're not, like, a lot of times back in the parking lot at the end.
对，对，对。天哪，天哪，多棒的一部纪录片啊。是的。大多数影片的结局都不太好，或者说没有惊艳的结局。你知道我的意思吗？没有。它们不是那种，很多时候最后又回到了停车场。
Oh, you mean the guy who climbs the ice waterfall at night by himself with no ropes? Doesn't end well? Oh, the guy with the bears? The guy who did all those cute movies of the bears? That one I still need to see. Oh, yeah. Yeah, yeah. Also, I got busted on not seeing The Revenant the other night at dinner with my parents and my husband
哦，你是说那个晚上独自一人、不系绳索去爬冰瀑的家伙？结局不太好？哦，那个跟熊在一起的家伙？拍了那么多可爱熊熊电影的那个家伙？那部我还没看呢。哦，对。对，对。还有，前几天我和我父母还有我丈夫吃晚饭时，因为我说“Snuggie（带袖毯）”就像《荒野猎人》里那个穿熊皮衣的家伙，结果我没看过《荒野猎人》的事当场被戳穿了
because I said that a snuggie was like that guy in the Revenant who wears the bear suit. Leo DeCabre. Yeah, like, truly everything. Everyone is like, what are you talking about? You're talking about Leonardo DiCaprio, like the, you know, Oscar winner, the actor, the guy. He's not the guy. He's Leonardo DiCaprio. He doesn't wear a bear suit.
因为我说一个带袖毯就像《荒野猎人》里穿熊皮衣的家伙。莱昂纳多·德卡布里。对，真的，什么都行。每个人都说，你在说什么？你说的是莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥，那个，你知道的，奥斯卡奖得主，那个演员，那个家伙。他不是那个家伙。他是莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥。他没穿熊皮衣。
Like, I guess he gets attacked. I didn't see it, I was too afraid. It's stunning. You should just see that one scene. Or just watch the YouTube special on how they shot that scene. Yeah. It's amazing.
我觉得他被袭击了。我没看，我太害怕了。这太震撼了。你应该去看看那一幕。或者直接看YouTube上关于他们是怎么拍那一幕的特辑。对。太棒了。
That seems like at a safe distance. Oh, my God. There's also a video, a YouTube video about the guys getting prepared to shoot the YouTube video which is amazing. That seems like a safe enough. It's mainly just in the parking lot
那好像是一个安全的距离。哦，天哪。网上还有一个视频，一个关于这帮家伙准备去拍那个YouTube视频的YouTube视频，这也太棒了。那看起来算是一个足够安全的距离了。主要就是停在停车场里
and putting on Patagonia's and shit, but it's good. No, I need to be pretty far afield, I think of the central experience. I don't really want it. Wait, go back to the fear thing. Oh, well, yeah, I think the fear is that people don't like, that they won't like me and that they won't think of,
然后穿上巴塔哥尼亚（Patagonia）之类的夹克，不过挺不错的。不，我需要去到更远的地方，我觉得我是指核心体验之外。我其实不太想。等等，回到恐惧那个话题。哦，好吧，对，我想恐惧是人们不喜欢，他们不会喜欢我，而且他们不会觉得，
like, yeah, that I'll be wearing a Patagonia jacket and I'll be like. They're great jackets. They're great jackets. They're expensive. Well, they're expensive, but if you're a size large, they're great. They're great. Sorry, I just had to put that out there. They're telling just what you need to tell, yeah.
就像，对，我会穿着巴塔哥尼亚夹克，然后我会像这样。它们是好夹克。它们是好夹克。它们很贵。嗯，它们很贵，但如果你穿大号的，它们就很棒。它们真的很棒。抱歉，我只是不得不说出来。他们就是在说你需要说的话，对吧。
So that fear of when you're up there on stage and they're not going to like you, if you play that out in your head, is it like that, oh, my God, I have no place to go. I can't hide. Right, because you still do it. Yeah, I mean, it feels like a social thing. I like it, that I'm going to have to be up here and they're all going to see me, like, just, like, choking and floundering
所以那种恐惧，当你站在舞台上，而他们不喜欢你时，如果你在脑子里把这个情景推演一遍，是不是那种，哦，天哪，我无处可去。我无处可藏。没错，因为你还是会去做。是的，我的意思是，这感觉像是一场社交活动。我喜欢的是，我将不得不站在这里，而他们都会看着我，就像，只是，像这样，哽咽和笨拙
and being out of control and all the things that if I succeed at, they'll see me as a master of, like, you know, the moment and, like, chaos and power or whatever. Not that I see it that, but I think that would be the other. side of it. Not that I think I'm like the master of chaos. I would imagine that you'd have to find a place of like the perfect combination between sort of an adversarial relationship with the audience, right? So that you you feel sort of puffed up and strong like a worthy adversary and you can defend yourself. But then also kind of be a teammate with the audience too. You want to try to find that connection with them. I bet that's a really, that's a real challenging place for stand-ups.
而且失去控制，以及所有这些事情，如果我成功了，他们就会视我为掌控时刻、混乱和力量的大师，诸如此类。并不是说我这样看待它，但我认为这将是硬币的另一面。并不是说我觉得自己像个混乱大师。我想你一定得找到一个地方，介于与观众的某种对抗关系之间达到完美的结合，对吧？这样你就会觉得自己有点膨胀、强大，就像一个势均力敌的对手，你可以保护自己。但同时也要成为观众的队友。你想试着与他们建立那种联系。我敢打赌，对单口喜剧演员来说，那真是一个极具挑战性的位置。
I don't think I'd ever have the spine to do it. But it's like a date. Terrifying. I think of it like a date. Like, you're like, the person could think. I actually think you don't have the balls to do it. It's fine. Or the spine. No skeletal structure whatsoever.
我想我永远没有勇气去做这件事。但这就好比是一场约会。太吓人了。我把它想象成一次约会。就像，你会想，对方可能会觉得。我其实觉得你没有胆量做这个。没关系。或者说没有脊梁骨。完全没有任何骨骼结构。
Or sack. I don't think you have the sack. I don't think you have any of the undercarriage to do it. Sorry, Jim. Look, I don't have that undercarriage either. And I, it's okay. You do. How often are you still getting up there and doing stand-up?
或者没有蛋蛋。我觉得你没有蛋蛋。我觉得你的下半身不具备做这事的任何条件。对不起，吉姆。听着，我的下半身也没有。而且我，没关系。你有。你现在多久还上台去讲单口喜剧？
Well, in L.A., I was going, so I usually go up at Largo. and I was trying to go like twice a week while I was there because I want to make a new special. And that's harder, obviously, like when I want to put the baby to bed and, you know, and I like it when Ben sees my sets because especially after having the baby, it's like, oh, I guess I'm just this person who like complains about like almost everything all the time.
嗯，在洛杉矶的时候，我会去，所以我通常去Largo演出。我在那里的时候尽量每周去两次，因为我想做一个新的特辑。这当然更难，比如我想让宝宝睡觉的时候，你知道的，而且我喜欢让本看到我的演出，因为特别是有了孩子之后，就好像，哦，我猜我就是那种几乎对所有事情都在抱怨的人。
I really want him to see me as someone who other people think is like literally in the cheapest way, like popular. Like I would like him to, you know, like everything's fine. But I'm just like, that's such a good, I think it's such a good look, you know, up there on stage. If they're liking you, it's like, oh, right, I forgot that there's this powerful person and it is nice. But it's also really scary. And, but I have to do it. Do you make him the butt of any jokes, either intentionally or unintentionally?
我真的很想让他把我当作一个被其他人认为，直白点说，就是很受欢迎的人。我希望他能，你知道的，就好像一切都很好。但我只是觉得，这真是一个很好的形象，你知道的，站在舞台上。如果他们喜欢你，就会觉得，哦，对了，我忘了这里有个很有权势的人，这感觉很好。但这也真的很可怕。不过我必须得做这件事。你会把他当作任何笑话的靶子吗，不管是故意还是无意？
Well, like when you're sharing your stuff about home and the kid and adjusting to that, the new life in your house, house like did you do you back into sort of throwing him under the bus at all i used to do that on talk shows with my wife and then she she's straightened me out did you ask permission or would you just like i didn't and then i got my snout smacked uh and then i started asking for permission and then she started saying no and then i started looking for different material sure sure sure yeah jenny i want to talk about i want to leave you with marcel the shell because it's so good i watched the movie last night it's so good here's what i need to say i've been a fan of marcelle the shell as she was on forever. I know it's been like over 10 years
嗯，就像当你分享家里和孩子的事情以及适应这种生活时，你家里的新生活，你会不会有点顺带把他也数落一番？我以前在脱口秀节目里对我妻子这样做过，然后她把我的毛病给纠正过来了。你征求过许可吗，还是你就直接——我没有，然后我的鼻子挨了一记重拳，接着我开始征求许可，然后她开始说不，接着我就开始寻找不同的素材。确实，确实，是的。珍妮，我想谈谈，我想以《穿鞋子的贝壳马塞尔》结束采访，因为它太棒了。我昨晚看了这部电影，太棒了。这是我必须说的：我一直是马塞尔的粉丝，自从他一直在网上。我知道这已经有10年了吧
or something like that, right? Yeah. And I used to watch this videos all the time. And what I love about it is if you haven't seen it, all you need to know about it is in the title. It's literally Marcel, a shell, and he has shoes on. And you literally play a shell named Marcel. And he, how the voice, like, how the voice, why the voice? Are you sick of the voice?
或者类似的时间，对吧？是的。我以前经常看这些视频。我喜欢它的一点是，如果你没看过，你只需要看标题就能了解一切。它字面意思就是马塞尔，一个贝壳，而且他穿着鞋子。而你实际上是在给一个名叫马塞尔的贝壳配音。而他，那个声音，为什么是这个声音？你听腻这个声音了吗？
Tell us all things about Marcel because how did you think of him? And are you kind of like done or more, more, more? because I can't get enough of them. Oh, thanks. Thanks for saying that. Like, wait, sidebar really quick. I loved when Marcel played taps from his horn, which was a piece of hollow spiral macaroni.
给我们讲讲关于马塞尔的一切吧，因为你是怎么构思出他的？你觉得是差不多结束了，还是越多越好？因为我怎么都看不够。哦，谢谢。谢谢你这么说。等一下，插播一个题外话。我太喜欢马塞尔用他的号角吹奏熄灯号了，那个号角是一段空心的螺旋通心粉。
And he sleeps in his bread room, which is a bedroom made out of bread, which is fantastic. Bless him. And when he plays taps, he plays taps, that is, um, that's like my favorite part of the, that like sort of, it's a sad part. Yeah. It's sort of like a eulogy part.
他睡在他的面包房里，那是一个用面包做成的卧室，这太棒了。保佑他。当他吹奏熄灯号时，他吹奏了熄灯号，那就是，嗯，那就像是我最喜欢的部分，那有点像是一个悲伤的部分。是的。这有点像是一段悼词。
And it's so funny. And it's also so terribly sad. Macaroni. Yeah, it's like a shofar. In my culture, we call that a showfar. Yeah, for sure. A lot of secret Judaism put in there. I'm not sick of the voice.
真的太搞笑了。而且也超级无敌悲伤。通心粉。对，就像一个法螺。在我的文化里，我们把那叫作法螺。对，没错。里面融入了很多神秘的犹太文化。我可听不腻这个声音。
I love doing it. It feels like a, you know, like, I don't know, like a soothing thing. I do it by myself a lot. I like it. It came up one weekend when I was like in a hotel room, sharing hotel room with like five friends and everyone was like broke and we were all sharing a hotel room. and like every thing you could sleep on was being used.
我超爱配这个。感觉就像一个，你知道的，怎么说呢，就像一种抚慰人心的东西。我自己经常配着玩。我挺喜欢的。这个声音是有一天周末冒出来的，当时我在一个酒店房间里，跟大约五个朋友挤在一个酒店房间里，每个人都穷得叮当响，大家合住一个房间。基本上能躺下来睡觉的地方都占满了。
Like the cot and the two beds and like someone on the floor or whatever. And they were just like all men. And I felt like tiny and that it was like so messy and cramped in there. And I started to talk to like sort of rib people in that voice. And then my partner at the time had like promised that he was going to make a video for a little show in Williamsburg. He hadn't done anything yet. And he was like, could I interview? that voice and like maybe there will be a character and I'll um you know make something with it so he
比如折叠床、两张大床，还有人睡在地板上什么的。而且房间里全都是男的。我觉得自己好渺小，里面又乱又挤。我开始用那种声音跟他们开玩笑、逗闷子。然后我当时的伴侣曾答应过，要为威廉斯堡的一个小型展映做个视频。他当时什么都还没做。他就问：“我能采访一下那个声音吗？也许会有个角色，然后我……你知道的，用它做点东西。”所以他
interviewed me in that voice and then he made Marcel's body and then we just like oh cute that video it's so cool so is he still a part of all the stuff going forward yeah Dean Fleischer camp he's um he's the director and um we co-wrote it together with our friend Nick Paley and yeah yeah he's uh he did everything I love um when there's a million one-liners but you know what Marcel uses for skis are men's toenails. Yeah, toenails from a man. Toneil clippings, not the actual toenail, full toenails. Yeah, just the clippings.
用那种声音采访了我，然后做出了玛塞尔的身体，接着我们就……哦，好可爱，那个视频太棒了！那么他接下来还会参与所有的这些制作吗？对，迪恩·弗莱舍·坎普，他……他是导演，而且……我们和我们的朋友尼克·佩利一起联合编剧的，对，对，他……他包办了一切。我太喜欢……当里面出现无数金句的时候，你知道玛塞尔用什么当滑雪板吗？是男人的脚趾甲。对，男人的脚趾甲。脚趾甲剪下来的碎屑，不是真正的整个脚趾甲，是完整的脚趾甲。对，就是剪下来的碎屑。
Did I see a trailer for it that's coming out? Yes. Yeah, it's coming out June 24th through 824. What? And you filmed it like over a year ago, right? It took seven years to make. Wow. Jesus.
我看到它的预告片要上映了吗？是的。对，它将在6月24日通过824发行。什么？而且你们是一年多前拍的吧，对吗？总共花了七年才制作完成。哇。天哪。
Yeah, we finished it. I want to say in the winter of... Why did it take seven years? Well, because it's stop motion and we weren't, you know, we were like fully funded by Cinerich. It's like a, it's not a studio. It's like basically like getting arts grants, basically. And which also gave us total freedom.
对，我们做完了。我想大概是在……为什么花了七年时间？嗯，因为那是定格动画，而且我们没有……你知道的，我们获得了Cinerich的全额资助。这就像是一个……它不是那种大制片厂。基本上就像是拿艺术基金补助一样。这也给了我们绝对的自由。
Yeah, which is really great. And it took a long time. The film was improvised off of a long treatment. So we would like record, like improvise. And then Dean and Nick would go back and call through all the audio and start to make a script off of that and then write things that we should say and go back into more improvising
对，这真的很棒。而且花了很长时间。这部电影是在一个很长的故事大纲基础上即兴创作出来的。所以我们会录音，就像即兴发挥一样。然后迪恩和尼克会回去听遍所有的音频，并开始在此基础上写剧本，接着写出我们应该说台词的内容，然后再回去做更多的即兴发挥。
and that process itself took about a couple years. And then you would do the stop motion. Yeah, then I think the order was we locked like the audio play like everything that Marcel and his grandmother is the only other character besides Dean, grandmother
这个过程本身就花了大约好几年。然后你们再做定格动画。对，然后我想顺序是我们先敲定了音频，比如玛塞尔和他的祖母——除了迪恩之外唯一的另一个角色，祖母
played by Isabella Rossellini, who is incredible. Nice. She has a beautiful voice. Yeah. And so we did and she let us go to her farm to improvise, like when there's the farm? It's in New York. Yeah. City? Yeah, it's in this city.
由伊莎贝拉·罗西里尼配音，她简直太棒了。太好了。她有着一副动听的嗓音。对。我们去做了，她让我们去她的农场即兴表演，就是那个有农场的什么地方？在纽约。对。城市里？对，就在这个城市里。
It's so weird because I'm 56th Street. So, wow. Yeah, so strange. It's just a farm, and what do they, they just raise improvisers? That's amazing. Yeah, it's called yes and farm. Oh, my God, that's amazing. Yeah, I just love that.
这太诡异了，因为我就在56街。所以，哇。对，太奇怪了。那只是个农场，他们都在那儿干嘛，难道专门培养即兴演员吗？这太神奇了。对，那地方叫“是的，还有农场”（Yes and Farm）。哦天哪，太神奇了。对，我超喜欢那个。
I love that about her. Anyway, yeah. Yeah, so we recorded it all and then they filmed the live action because, like, Marcel is, you know, like he's in a physical house and obviously Dean is the real person that you sometimes see, like his hand
我太喜欢她这一点了。总之，对。对，所以我们把录音都做完了，然后他们才拍摄真人实景。因为，玛塞尔，你知道的，他身处一个真实的物理环境里，显然迪恩是真人，你有时能看到他，比如他的手
or him walking away. They filmed all the live action the whole movie's worth and then they filmed the stop motion animation on that. It's so good. I love it. I loved it so much. Please go see it if you haven't seen it. June 24th.
或者他走开的身影。他们把所有的真人实景部分——整部电影的实景——都拍完了，然后在这个基础上拍摄定格动画。太棒了。我太喜欢了。我超级喜欢。如果你们还没看的话，请务必去看。6月24日上映。
June 24th. It's my sister's birthday. Is that right? Happy birthday. Well, two of them, because they're twins. Oh, perfect. Both of them, then. What are both their names, well, quick.
6月24日。那是我姐姐的生日。是吗？生日快乐。嗯，有两个，因为她们是双胞胎。哦，太完美了，那两个都是咯。快说说她俩叫什么名字。
Tannis and Chandley. Good. And what about your brother? Chuck. Wow. Wait, why do we test me on this all the time? Jenny, it's such a pleasure. Thank you for being here.
塔尼斯和尚德莉。很好。那你哥哥呢？查克。哇。等下，为什么你们老是考我这些？珍妮，能请你来真是太荣幸了。谢谢你来到这里。
Jenny. Jenny. You're hilarious and a delight. You really are. You really are. You really are. This is really, really fun. Next time you're out in Silver Lake,
珍妮。珍妮。你太逗了，简直是个开心果。真的。真的。真的。这真的太好玩了。下次你来锡尔弗莱克（Silver Lake）的时候，
Come by the Smartless Studios. Oh, that'll be nice. They don't exist. Oh, they don't. You don't have to know. We're building a whole compound out there to rival Isabella Rossellini's Yes and Ranch. Yep, yes and ranch. Top of the Rock.
顺便来“聪明绝顶”（Smartless）工作室坐坐。哦，那太好了。它们根本不存在。哦，没有吗？你不用知道。我们正在那边建造一个巨大的园区，好去和伊莎贝拉·罗西里尼的“是的，还有牧场”（Yes and Ranch）一较高下。没错，“是的，还有牧场”。洛克菲勒中心顶层。
You can't miss it. It's gorgeous up there. Stop of the Rock. She's up there, hoeing. Anyway, honey, thank you. We love you. I'm so proud of you. And I'm excited for the movie.
你绝不会错过。上面风景美极了。洛克菲勒中心顶层。她就在上面，挥着锄头干活呢。总之，亲爱的，谢谢你。我们爱你。我为你感到骄傲。我也为这部电影感到兴奋。
I hope it does really well. Thank you so much. Thank you, Jenny. Please say hi to Ben. And Ida, tell her I miss her. I will. Bye, Jenny. Bye, bye, bye, honey.
希望它大卖。非常感谢。谢谢你，珍妮。请代我向本问好。还有艾达，告诉她我很想她。我会的。再见，珍妮。再见，再见，亲爱的。
Goodbye, goodbye. Okay, I'll go. I go now, right? Yeah, you go now. You go. You go. I go now. Goodbye.
再见，再见。好了，我该走了。我现在就走，对吧？对，你现在走。你走。你走。我走了。再见。
Bye. Bye. Bye. That's Jenny Slate, y'all. Yeah, I love it. She is great. Slate's a killer. She's a real killer.
再见。再见。再见。各位，那就是珍妮·斯蕾特。对，我太喜欢了。她太棒了。斯蕾特是个狠角色。她真的是个狠角色。
I know. Everybody knows her voices, right? But they don't know that she probably does all them because they're all so different. I did a, I did a, I did a small movie with her. She was on camera, not just the voice, the face, the whole acting. What was the movie? She's very, very good.
我知道。大家都知道她配过各种声音，对吧？但大家不知道的是，可能这些都是她一个人配的，因为每个声音都完全不同。我曾和她合作过一部小电影。她是真人出镜，不仅仅是配音，还有脸蛋，全方位的表演。那是部什么电影？她演得非常好。
I believe it's called The Longest Week. It wasn't a large film. But she was in it and she was great. I really had a good time with her. She's real fun. She's super fun, cute, funny, just adorable, super talented. Oh, my God. Great, great energy, great vibe.
我想片名叫《最长的一周》。那不是一部大制作电影。但她在里面表现得很棒。我和她合作得非常愉快。她真的很有趣。她超级有趣、可爱、搞笑、简直萌翻了，才华横溢。哦天哪。能量爆棚，氛围感绝佳。
She should teach improv and voiceover stuff. because she'd... I know, it was pretty good. Well, Will, so are you going to go back workout and finish that now? No, I was just finishing up, and I'm really rattled. Now I'm so hungry, obviously. Well, go get something to eat. And then I've got to go, I got to go meet Jason.
她应该去教即兴表演和配音之类的课程。因为她……我知道，这真的很不错。好了，威尔，所以你要回去健身然后把剩下的做完吗？不，我刚练完，而且我现在整个人脑子晕乎乎的。显然我现在饿极了。好吧，去吃点东西吧。然后我得走了，我要去见杰森。
We got a meeting. Yeah, we got a lunch meeting. Hey, so what are you going to eat prior to your one o'clock lunch? I am fucking... What's it going to be, though? Is it going to be a protein show? Are you going to ruin all the work you've done this morning? Punching that dumb white.
我们有个会议。对，我们有个午餐会。嘿，那你下午一点的午餐前打算吃点啥？我他妈的……到底要吃啥？会是蛋白质大餐吗？你会不会把自己今天早上辛辛苦苦做的一切都毁了？对着那个蠢白
bag. There it is. My energy is really plummeted in the last ten minutes. It's sugar. Yeah, no, I've noticed. All right, well, why don't we let you go? I think you're coming today. We're huge fans.
包一阵狂揍。就是这样。在过去的十分钟里，我的精力真的是急剧下降。是糖分作祟。对，没错，我也注意到了。好吧，那我们就不多留你了。我想你今天要来。我们都是你的超级粉丝。
Oh, wait, wait, wait, and do I just slam shut? Yeah, you just slam shut. If you're feeling a week, just go grab something that looks like it's got a lot of carbohydrates in it and just take a big bite. Bye. Smartless. Smartless. Smartless.
哦，等等，等等，我需要直接挂断吗？对，你直接挂断就行。如果你觉得虚弱，就去拿点看起来碳水化合物含量很高的东西，然后狠狠咬上一大口。再见。“聪明绝顶”。“聪明绝顶”。“聪明绝顶”。
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarf, and Bennett Barbico. Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“聪明绝顶”节目由迈克尔·格兰特·泰瑞、罗布·阿姆贾夫和本内特·巴巴里科100%有机纯手工打造。聪明绝顶。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。